foreign
Rachel one of the great cautions for
people who are on radio who do podcast
with media is whatever happens
don't get yourself canceled
oh yeah and John's alone I'm about to
get myself canceled
oh my gosh okay so the other day I
posted on social media I don't even have
my I've got them stuff from it of course
are you ready yes all right here's what
here's America here's what I posted it's
a text post on Instagram so there's no
pictures or anything no pictures just
like a black square with white fonts you
ready parents make no mistake Youth
Travel sports are for you not your kids
if athletic achievements is their only
way to connect with you they will give
up every weekend of their childhood
chasing a little ball to win your love
do what you're going to do that's fine
just be honest about the real
beneficiary
so then you said quick edit the bottom
oh okay well hold on I'll tell you about
that okay so I posted that that is a
that is a freaking like
black and white statement though it is
it is and make no mistake Youth Travel
sports are for you like there's you gave
no like possibly two percent the kid
loves it right like you went hard and
out of my opinions
and in the in the in the post itself I
said hey this is my working hypothesis I
think I'm right but I'd love to hear
from you and did you hear them two hours
I lost 1 500 followers just forget this
guy
um hundreds of opinions come came flying
in which is what I asked for I loved it
yeah and one of the most common
statements early on was oh this is one
of those guys that's never done sports
or spoken like a true non-sport guy so I
did something I almost never do hey I
read the comments I never did that and I
did this time and B I actually plugged
back in and said just in case you're
wondering I played travel baseball
before it was travel baseball back when
it was we were traveling all over with
all-star teams and stuff I was pretty
good then I was a two-year multi-sport
starter in high school at Varsity
starter in high school and then I went
to college on a college on a athletic
scholarship and then after college I was
running around with it getting my head
kicked in with a professional MMA team
so I spent my whole life doing this okay
and yes I've got two little kids now and
the Machine was kicking up and I started
asking myself
a this is way different than when I was
involved oh man as I went down the
rabbit hole
good God Almighty look at this
national uh nationally
visitor spending associated with
sporting events which consists primarily
of Youth and amateur sports tournaments
reached roughly 92 billion dollars
in the most recent data available
92 billion dollars it is a
multi-multi-multi-multi-billion dollar
industry so here's what can I throw
another step because here's what's crazy
so the typical parent spends 693 dollars
per per child per year
so 700 now if you go into the travel
world
frequently as frequently you can spend
up to 12
000 per year with that money going
towards travel and team fees
according to a survey by project play
again the average Sports out there is
693 dollars but parents spend on excess
twelve thousand dollars for travel and
that does not include private training
clinics or sports summer camps which
also can cost hundreds to thousands of
dollars even more per year and so I this
conversation started about a decade ago
when I was working in higher ed and I
was meeting with my friends were
athletic trainers in the number of
athletic trainers saying hey we're
starting to see joint injury usage
injuries that we have normally only been
reserved for the elderly
oh 18 year olds who have been playing
not only just baseball since they were
five but a particular position that they
went and got a special coach for and
special this and special that and they
play on this team and this team in this
team and they've done the same
repetitive motion for the last 16 years
during some of the most critically
developmental critical developmental
moments of their life and their
shoulders look like the shoulders of 80
year olds and so I started thinking wow
that doesn't sound right
um and so man if you go down the rabbit
hole the scholarship yeah oh go ahead
yeah yeah the links between travel
Sports and professional sports is
virtually zero yeah right
um the psychological challenge that's
what I'm saying yeah yes the
psychological challenges the social
isolation the travel the altered
relationship with families the research
is starting to come out saying whoa whoa
whoa what are we doing what are we doing
so I started asking myself
why are we doing this because I want my
kids to play sports because I feel like
I got a lot from them I learned
discipline I learned how to fail in
public I learned all these great things
but to the tune of every weekend of our
family right to the tune of we're paying
off debt yet we're spending 12 Grand per
kid to play tennis to play hockey to go
on all these soccer tournaments right
and the most common feedback I get is is
twofold number one my kid loves it
and here's my response to that here's my
response to that my I woke up this
morning and shoot my wife's out of town
and so it was just me and Josephine my
six-year-old she asked me right when she
woke up stumbles in gives me her morning
hug and says can I have ice cream she
loves it she loves it can I have ice
cream for breakfast no Joseph oh I know
can I have pancakes and you tell it's my
job as a parent to say hey I know you
love this and
if you miss every weekend what happens
to your academics if you are only with
this group of 12 people in this group
forever yes you make some deep
relationships but you miss a whole
Cascade of people that are different
than you that think different that
worship differently
that's a great point because that was
going to be my feedback to you of like
yeah but what if the kid's so good and
they love it but you're still the parent
like you're the parents I love it they
oh yeah because my kid would eat ice
cream every step of the way so the
financial the financial piece I never
like to say I would never spend x amount
on a car I would never spend that much
for a vacation right because you it's
all percentages it's all percentages so
for some families 12 000 people there
are some families that are going into
debt they are or they're not doing
things that they otherwise would be
would benefit their financial positions
it would help their family out in
general yes and so it's become a
detriment financially to me that's a
hard stop it's like you like we're never
on the show gonna going to say go into
debt for things so like if you're
digging yourself in a financial hole for
this it's not smart it's not wise long
term for yourself for your family it's
not wise now if it's a small percentage
of your income knock your lights up man
do your thing if you yeah right it's not
a moral thing based on the money but I
but I would caution I'm like but there
here's here's my thing can I tell you
mine okay we have three kids okay our
oldest is in second grade and I have had
I've had probably five conversations I'd
say in the last like six months I don't
want to be dramatic here I was gonna say
like it last week but it's probably been
over the six months that you know you're
talking to a parent it's like yeah we're
gonna put her in dance
and we have to do the dance
Championship League where they go and
travel because if she can't she doesn't
do that she's not gonna make Middle
School dance team because Middle School
Dance seems to be full of girls that
have been dancing right I'm using this
example and then if you make if you
don't make Middle School there's no way
you're gonna make high school if you
don't make high school they're gonna do
drugs and they're going to die because
they're not gonna be here but you plug
in you plug in any other sport right
whether it's soccer baseball so John
honestly as a parent though in our
County in that in Nashville it's
probably very heightened too I feel like
I feel like most everyone does travel
Sports it's rare to meet a family that
doesn't in in this I mean seriously it's
crazy everyone does so I even went down
that rabbit hole where I was like oh my
gosh okay here's is this
here's the data this is from a study
here
um done in 2016.
there were 322 athletes invited to the
2015 National Football League scouting
combine 80 percent 87 percent of whom
played multiple Sports in high school
and 13 only who only played football
and what this goes on to say is the
greatest gift you can give your kids is
to let them play a bunch of different
things and let them have fun and
naturally gravitate towards a thing with
specialization happening later on in
high school and into college okay but
what if they don't make the but what if
that's a reality though you go to play
sixth grade soccer here's why if they're
athletic they're gonna be athletic well
if they're LeBron James you'll know at
about age six right everyone around that
kid he signed his high school in high
school he said his his tennis shoe deal
right right and there's always the story
of Rudy yes we know that there's the
story of Rudy for most of us the anxiety
intention and expense and frenetic
schedules yeah cause more challenge to
our kids than
they're good at soccer